en
[Müzik]
uygun o
[Alkış]
ama
bazı temizlemiyorum sizi bir gorilin şey
yapacağı şekilde sizi selamlıyorum
ormanda goril ile karşılaşırsanız bir
gün
diyorsa Hoş geldiniz burada güvendesiniz
demek Hoşgeldiniz
şimdi size bir bankacının çıldırıp
İstanbul'dan Ege'de bir kasabaya
gidişini anlatmayacağım Çünkü bu bankacı
çok çıldırdı
şimdi
Nişantaşı'ndaki o zaman Nişantaşı'nda
yaşıyordum Nişantaşı'ndaki evinden çıkıp
Ege gitsem dört saat beş saat sürebilir
ama ben size
kaç gündeyim son t60 kilometre gidersem
köprü trafiğine kullanmazsam ve yol
üzerindeki ülkelerde
göstereyim biraz
mı yoksa
saatte 60 kilometre yaparsam şöyle bir
12 günde falan oganda yollara biliyorum
Hangi bana kötü Gerçekten çok çıldırdı
şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
neden oranda
beş yaşındayken televizyon yayınları
başladığında ilk izlediğim çizgi film
Tarzan the
Ha bir de pardon pardon Bir de
bankacıyım sefer rehberi olmaya gidiyor
Aman Allahım Gerçekten delirmiş
olmalıyım
tarz an çok yüksek yeşil araştırın
olduğu yağmur ormanları balta girmemiş
yağmur ormanlarında yaşayan
o çok yakışıklı bir adamdı
Ailesi görüntüler komşuları şempanzeler
Efsane bir hayat yaşıyor Ben de böyle
çocuk çocuk izliyorum bir de kız
arkadaşım var arkadaşlar J yani
Sen neden olmuşsun
böyle hayaller kurdum Bizimki Bana su
köye gitmeyeyim haftaya gitmeliyim ama
nasıl gideceğim Sonra Hem istediğin
üniversiteyi kazandığım sonra yurt
dışında bir çıkan sudan burs kazandım
sonra Türkiye'nin ve firmalarında
çalışmaya başladım iki kuruş bir araya
koyar koymaz Afrika'ya gitmeye kalktım
ve bu
1999 yılında gittiğim ilk seferi
Tanzanya ve efsanevi bütün belgesellerin
çekildiği seven geçiyor gittim Sonra
2005 yılında
bu yasal olarak yasal olarak bu çok
önemli Uganda'da birilerinin peşine
düştüm Belki de tarzına Bunu söyleyip
duruyorum sonra Ruanda'da grileri gördüm
Bir de Goriller sınır tanımadığı için
altı tane silahlı erkekle tek turist
olarak
pasaportumda müdür almadan Ormanlardan
kongo'ya girdi
ve
e2005 yılında Ocak ayında demiştim 2005
yılının ekiminde elimde iki Valizle Ben
uganda'ya yerleştirdim Şimdi
ben da da
Goriller ve bende oganda da şöyle
bu
hapse girdim
hazırlıyor adım burnum kırıldı
kaburgalarının kırıldığı eve hırsız
girdiğinde yatağın altında saklanmak
zorunda kaldım ya Bir Hırsızın Peşinden
köpeğimde gitti Bir de onu aradım ama bu
olayları saymazsak Efsane bir 11 yıl
yaşadım
Bir de bu arada
pardon Bir de bu arada
hayatımı değiştirecek şeyler öğrendi
Aslında şöyle denir Afrika sana ne kattı
Afrika sana ne kalktı bu kadar kadar
yaşadım burada ne katkı sana çünkü biz
Hem olayları insanları bize ne kattığı
ile değerlendiririz İlla bir şey
alacağız İlla bir şey alacağız Ama bazı
deneyimlerin bize bir şey katması için
aslında bizden birşeyleri alması
gerekebilir
Afrika benden telaşı aldı hırs aldı şu
kibri almıştır diye mide ediyorum
kaygıyı aldı
Hatta bir miktarda para mı aldı
arkadaşlar ilk sıfırı içirmesi girişimde
bayağı bir miktar para kaybettim aldı
Aldı aldı da zaten Bunlar benim omuzuma
yükmüş aldıktan sonra bana kalanlar bana
yetti de arttı bile Çünkü bunlar benim
kurtulmak istediğim insanın özüne dönmen
için kurtulmam gereken yüklenmiş
bir de şöyle bir
işim oldu Ben Afrika'da yerleşik ilk tek
Türk sıfır rehberi oldu
oldu şimdi size bugün bu deneyimlerden
öğrendiğim şeyleri bu 11 yıldan
öğrendiğim bazı şeyleri paylaşmak
istiyorum ama size şöyle şeyler
söyleyeceğim Yani pek çok sosyal bir de
daha arkadaşlar bazı kişiler diyorlar ki
çok fakirler Ah çok Sefiller Ah Şafak de
böyle fakirler böyle şeyler söyleyeceğim
hem de fakir ama mutlu asla demeyeceğim
çünkü bu çok kibirli bir ifade yani
fakirsin gülümseme
Şimdi de deneyimlerimi paylaşmak
istiyorum
o gülen yüz Gülen yüzün her kapıyı
açtığını öğrendim şimdi
bu insanlar yanlış anlaşılmalar için iki
tane şartımız var
konuşan bir insan dinleyen bir insan
Yani bir insan konuştu bir insanda
dinlediği an yanlış anlaşılmaların önü
açılıyor özellikle aynı dili
konuşuyorsanız Ben ne diyorum sen ne
diyorsun denize devamlı konuşmak
gerçekten çok riskli bir hareket
gülümsemenin her türlü kapıyı açtığını
öğrendim çünkü
bazı ülkelere
girişlerim yani belgelerim vizesiz
vesaire ya da para vermeden girişlerin
trafik polislerinin elinden ehliyetsiz
yıllarca Kurtuluş larım
sınırlarda vize ücreti verme işlerin
hepsi gülümseyerek oldu vücut dili çok
önemli yani söylediğimiz kelimelerden
çok daha fazla önemli artık bunu
biliyoruz ama bu mesela
bu şöyle vücut dili kazaları olabilir mi
saldırın bir hareketi var bir elini
yumruk yapıp Diğerini de şu şekilde açıp
ikisini birbirine hızlıca kavuşturduğu
newsone bu Türkiye'de çok riskli bir
harekettir biliyorsunuz buganda dolu
demek ya bir yer doğruysan şekilde
ellerinizi şok atarak birleştirir siniz
mesela o mandalı bir arkadaşım
İstanbul'da okuyan bir arkadaşım dolmuş
şoförlerine gel gel gel Diyen dolmuş
şoförlerinin yok Ben gelmeyeyim sizin
dolmuş dolu dediği için
hastanelik olacak kadar dayak yedi
arkadaşlar o yüzden gülümseyeceksin iz
en garantisi bu
bir ondan önce çalıştığım firmalarda
ciddi durmanın önemli insan olmakla
neredeyse eşit olduğu öğretildi bize ne
yazık ki ama
Ben şunu öğrendim diye tren de böyle
olurmuş
bakalım
Gülümse bütün gülümsediğim Çünkü şöyle
gülümsediğini an Afrika'da herkes size
başında toplanıyor bir şey mi oldu bir
şey mi oldu bir şey mi oldu bakalım
biraz
Evet hop pardon
o
ciddiyet
prensiplerle olan bir şeymiş surattaki
ciddiyet doğrudan suratsızlık mış
görüyorsunuz
suratsız Halim ve sürat suratlı Halim
öğrendiğim diğer önemli bir konu
Afrika'da zaman çok farklı akıyor bir
tane atasözü var haraka rakı hayvana
baraka şimdi bando dillerinde Arap köle
tüccarları nedeniyle girmiş Arapça
kelimeler var ha rakı haraka hareket
hareket
hayn abraka bereketi olmaz çok çabuk
hareket ederseniz bu işin hareketi olmaz
Pole Pole yavaş yavaş Afrika dilinde
zaman
gerçekten çok farklı akıyordu Afrika'da
Mesela
çiftçilerle bir toplantımız var bir
şirkette çalışıyorum hani o parayı
yatırdıktan sonra üzerinden yükleri
attım ya bir miktarda para kaybetti bu
sonra bir şirkette çalışıyorum
çiftçilerle projelerimiz var
Sürdürülebilir tarım projeleri
Çiftçilere diyorum ki yarın sabah
dokuzda
toplanalım
şimdi bu anda da resmi değil İngilizce
yani okula giden Herkes İngilizce
anlamayabilir
diyorum ki 9'da gelelim yine de emin
olmak için çevirmen ediyorum ki çıktı
arkadaşlarım söyler misin Yarın sabah
9'da buluşacağız bu dünya Çiftçi
arkadaşlara diyor ki işte gelelim işte
tougen de bilmem ne sağlığı satılıyor
shoo arkadaşım sağlasa tulug anda
dilinde 3.00 demek baksana alıyorum 9.00
bu Öpüyorum ki Hacı bacım beni daha hani
çok iyi değilim anladım Yani bir daha
söyle bir daha söyler misin lütfen durum
arkadaşlar Hani yarın sabah 9'da gelsin
Çünkü de şöyle bir şey var Afrika'da hiç
kimse hiçbir yere
yok şöyle değil baktığımda gelmez
demeyeyim vaktinde gelir senin
söylediğin vakit de gelmez Çünkü her şey
vaktinde olur olması gereken vakitte
olursan 3'de 5'de her şey olduğu zaman
olur canım ki 9'da O diyor ki 3'te yoksa
bu dedim neyse yani artık Yarın saat
dokuzda olmasa da o arkadaşlar geldi
böyle onun 11 civarı herkes standı
şaşırdım o zaman dedi savasa ton Bunlar
geldi ayet mantıklı anlamadım
bu ederim yanlış anlıyorum yıllar sonra
tanzanya'da bir duvar saati gördüm
arkadaşlar
bu duvar saati böyleydi
Bak şimdi bizim saatimiz bu
Evet şimdi coğrafya bilgilerimizi
tazeleyelim Ekvator kuşağı
geceler gündüzler birbirine eşitliği
öğrendik de bunu hepimiz coğrafya
derslerinde öğrendik ama gelgelelim
oraya gidince bu bilgileri bir tazelemek
gerekiyor
Ekvator kuşağında tanzanya'da Uganda'da
Kenya'da Güneş Her gün sabah yedide
doğuyor Güneş her gün akşam 7'de batıyor
da tüm yıl değişmiyor ileri geri şu bu
falan yok Gündüz 12 saat gece 12.00
1.00 ve saati farklı söylüyormuş
arkadaşlar Hepsi farklı söylermiş Mesela
saat 7'de güneş doğduğu için güneşin
birinci saati diyorlarmış
saat 8'de güneş Doğalı iki saat olduğu
için 2.00 diyorlarmış 3.00 nedir
Bizim meşhur savasa tüm Yani saat
93 demekmiş Çünkü diyor ki Aslında yarın
Güneş doğduktan 3 saat sonra buraya
gelin diyor Bu aşağı öğlen bakıyoruz
öğlen saat altı şurada görüldüğü gibi
altı diyor ki bizim 12 dediğimizde Güneş
doğduktan altı saat sonra gelin diyor
çünkü tüm yıl aynı şimdi
9.00 neyin dokuzuncu saati
hiç birşeyin dokuz saati değil 3.00
neyin üçüncü saati Güneş doğduktan sonra
üçüncü saat çok mantıklı değil mi
gerçekten zaman her şey pek çok şey
farklı ve çok fazla şeyi saymıyorlar ama
saydıkları şeyleri de bir farklı
söylüyorlar mesela
ilk gittiğim zaman yolda yürüyorum o
zaman bir tanesi geldi Yorgan da dedi ki
saatini bana sat Tövbe Estağfirullah
oluyor dedim saatini bana sat dedim
arkadaşım diye Satayım sana zaten saatin
çok güzel saatini bana sat satmıyorum
dedim atıyorum bir anlamda düşünüyorum
ama benim kolumu keserim acaba falan
hani
şey dedi bana
hme Adam dedi beyazların saati
Afrikalıların bahçı var ben para
verirsem saat satın alabilirim Ama sen
parayla zaman satın alamazsın dedim
Evet şimdi
her şeyi farklı bir açıdan bakmayı
öğrendim çoğunlukla da
tam tersinden mesela Afrika'da
bu şişman güzeldir Çünkü şişman
sağlıklıdır bu oradaki pek çok hastalık
insanların zayıflamasıyla başladığı için
hiç kimse hastalıklı bir kadın istemez
kadın olarak bakıyorum sağlıklı bir
kadın ister pek çok hastalık hata
içerdiği hastalığının Selim derler Selim
zayıf demek zayıflamak demek o yüzden
şişman güzeldir bir sonra ben kilo
verdiğim zaman elinde çalışan katsın
diye bir kadın vardı
kardeşim sayılır artık kahramanı diyordu
ki ya Sen zayıflamışsın demiyordu Çünkü
zayıflamışsın demek o kadar kötü bir şey
ki hastasın sen de mi Ona diyordu ki
kafam büyümüş
Bu kaçıncı hem kafam giymedi Hayır
kafamı yedi diyordu Ben de diyordum Peki
ne diyeyim çünkü zayıflamışsın Demek
gerçekten Hakaret gibi birşey sonra
Eczaneden ilaç alıyorum diyor ki bana
tok karnına Günde 3 kez
Şimdi ben diyorum ya yemeklerden sonra
birer tane Hayır diyor tok karnına Günde
3 kez
yemeklerden sonra bir şey değil mesela
baktık günde iki kez yemek yiyor Evet
şimdi ne oldu benim şimdi üç kez tok
karnına ve o sırada
2010-2011 yılı istatistiklerine göre bu
Gun dalın neredeyse nüfusunun üçte biri
günde tek öğün yemekle günü geçiriyordu
ve yani demek ki günde Sadece bir kez
Tok olabilirler Bir kez ilaçla
alabilirler
sonra hergün günlük ve o öğünlük yemek
yapılıyor Hem neden böyle yapıyoruz
diyorum Sonra ve düşünüyorum ki
yaşadıkça öğreniyorum Tabii ki bunları
odanda halkın o yüzde 15'inin elektriğe
erişimi var elektriğe erişimi var
ifadesinde tanımını yapayım size bir
yerde bir düğme var basıyorsunuz ampul
Yanıyor bu kadar elektrik buzdolabı
falan yok yani her şey doğayı o kadar
yakın ki hani siz hiç gördünüz mü
herhangi bir belgeselde de arkasının
yemek üzere avlanan bir aslan randa
böyle bir yerde İşte sonra kaçırmada
diyordu ki zaten affet affet etmeyince
çirkinleşiyor Sun diyordu yapıyorum yani
böyle çirkin bir insan mı oluyorum
şirketleşiyor muyum vesaire affet affet
mence çirkinleşiyor Sun Çünkü
bu şekilde
affetmeyen insan Kaşlarını çatar mış
affetmeyen insan bu şekilde dururmuş
oganda da ve genelde afrikada
çirkinlikle eşdeğerde kaşlarını çatmak
ve affedin insan güzelleşirmiş
Şimdi size
ama biz yıllarımızı saklarız dikişlerimi
zaman deriz estetik olsun kimse görmesin
hiç kimse belli olmasın Hani şuraya
düştük ay Şimdi belli olacak
bu Afrika'da insanlar yaralarını gururla
taşır Çünkü
ergenlikten erişkinliğe geçiş
Vücudun bir tarafını kesme bu yara dövme
dir bir vücuduna birşeyde delme
dudağında bir tabak Faruk adının ve
acılarla insan olgunlaşır ve hiç kimse
yarasını paylaşmaz yaralı insan olmanın
insan demektir sonra
odalı evlerde yaşarlar Sadece uyumak
için kullanırlar misal 4 odalı evde
yaşayan bir ugandalı arkadaşımı ziyarete
gitmiştim aile altı kişilik evi dolaştım
3 oda boş bir odada hepsi iç Odalar öyle
duruyor Çünkü bir aradalar ve şu
gördüğünüz gibi tek odalı evlerde
yaşıyorlar sonra
şap her rengi iç çamaşırı istediğimde
siyah veriyorlardı ve bu Uganda'nın
başkenti Kamp Alanı tüm yıl ısı şeması
tüm yıl aynı ısıda bu için hiç kimse ne
Havayı Koklayan adamı dinliyor ne
meteoroloji haberleri hiçbir şey
dinlemiyordum Tabii ki başka doğadan çok
şey öğrendim çünkü bu kadar yıl sayısını
anlatamadığım kadar çok sıfır yaptım ve
Safari rehberliği yaptım Doğa en
kıymetli öğretmenmiş onu dinlemeyi
öğrendim Mesela şimdi erkekler Siz bir
dinleyin
kadınları tavlamak için ya çok
gösterişli olacaksınız ya da garip
hareketler yapacaksınız şimdi bu garip
hareketler nedir Hani böyle
belgesellerde görürsünüz Bazı hayvanlar
çok acayip hareketler yapıyor bunları
dişlerin dikkatini çekmek içindir ya
dans edersiniz insan dünyasında yüze
erkek dünyasının meşhur Garip Hareketi
nedir kavga
o kavga edersiniz Eğer doğada
farkedilmezse niz
Ben göremiyorum
göremiyorum gönlümü çekemiyor
göremiyorum ya Kendi halinizde böyle
kamufle olmuş gibi kamuflaj denir
yıkaması olur görünmez siniz bir risksiz
bir hayatımız olur Çünkü sizi
anlayamazlar ya da gösterişli ama riskli
bir hayat sürersiniz şimdi
ve bu konuşma olamamış bu daha bebek
zürafa Çünkü Bilmiyorum
şimdi size ya Kaç hayvan göstereceğim bu
hayvanların ortak yönü nedir sizce
var yani o göstermek istiyorum da ben de
dahil daha da ki iri hayvanların tamamı
vejeteryan dır Western yanları
kitaphaber
Mesela
10 eden 16 yaşında bir çocuğa şey
sormuştum en çok hangi
hayvanları beğendim demiştim o da
demişti ki bana öğle yemeği vakti gelmiş
galiba Ben sana abla demişti köfte
olanlarla olmayanlar mı
var yani avlarmı Avcılar mı hayvanlar
ikiye ayrılır köfte olanlar olmayanlar
avlananlar ve Avcılar doğuda bütün
hayvanlar doyduğu zaman durur bir tek
insan doyduğu zaman durmazin yani oha da
Hayvan gibi yeme denir nedense ve
Afrika'daki fastfood
yazık ki bu şekilde sade edebiliyorum
doğada insanı insanı Pardon hayvanlar
kulaklarıyla hayatta kalırlar dinleyerek
Çünkü devamlı dinleyerek doğayı
avcıların geldi geldiğini gelmediğini
dinlerler ve bu şekilde ömürleri uzar
insanlar için ise hiç durmadan konuşur
Bu da kendi hem kendi hayatlarını kendi
etrafındaki insanların hayatlarını
kısaltır
bir Doğada bir tek insan çöp yapar ama
hayvanlar kendi arkalarında hiçbir Ne
yapmam acısına hiçbir şekilde çöp
bırakmazlar tertemiz ler Birtek İnsanlar
çöp bırakır
anlatacak çok şeyim var ama ne yazık ki
vaktim çok az
size ya söylemek istediğim bir kaç şey
daha var Yani insanlar Güya işte
hayvanlarda mantık yoktur da insanlarda
mantık vardır ama baka dolayı
izlediğinde şunu görüyorum ki
hayvanların yaptığı her şeyde bir mantık
var mantıksız şeyleri nedense insanlar
yapıyor mesela karnı doğrusu diye
çalışıyor sonra kilo vermek için koşuyor
parayı cüzdana koyuyor cüzdanı çantaya
koyuyor Ondan sonra ayakkabıyı kutuyu
koyuyor kutuyu ayakkabılığın komik
koyuyoruz sonra devamlı bir şey başka
bir şey içine koyuyor yani ve bunların
hepsini ayrı ayrı para veriyor bu
devamlı bir şey bir şeyin içine koyma
merakı pek çok sektörü bu hafta
kurmasını sağlıyor sonra bir sürü şeyi
yapmayı öğreneceğini bir tane şeyi çok
iyi yapmayı öğreniyor devamlı onu
yapıyor devamlı onu yapıyor sıkılıyor
Buna da ne diyor meslek diyor
Şu sonra nerede bir hiç insan olmayan
bir manzara görse o cennet gibi diyor
sonra diyor ki insan sosyal bir
varlıktır diyor
bu
sonra ama eski kıyafet giymeye utanıyor
ama eskitilmiş kıyafeti yeni Kıyafetten
daha fazla para verip satın alıyor Çünkü
insan bir kıyafeti eskitmek değil Onu
eskitmiş olmak istiyor
Bu Son olarak size bir anımı paylaşmak
istiyorum
bu
Nişantaşı'nda Arkadaşlarla buluştuk işte
yenildi içildi hani böyle biz belli bir
saatten sonra çöp kamyonları dolaşmaya
başlar hani böyle bir diye bir sesi
vardır çöp kamyonlarının debriyajın
kızını boşalma sesi
oturuyoruz bu ses geldi cama koştum
filler geldi diye
bu Sonra baktım çöp kamyonu sesiymiş
arkadaşlarımı anlamadım ben kendime
gülmeye başladım
bu bana anlattı ki ben Afrika'da
olmasamda artık Afrika Benim için de
teşekkür ediyorum şu